Knit it Now memember recently requested
instruction to make finished slashes in
the middle of a knitted piece.
She wanted to convert a hand knitting
pattern that used this technique.
First, have a cast on rag
or knitted swatch ready.
These need to be large enough to fill the
number of needles in the slash they'll be
used to make the second half
of the slash easier to knit.
I'm assuming you know how to put your
machine into hold position, so that any
needles that are pulled all
the way out do not knit.
I'll refer to the right set of stitches.
The center set of stitches, which is the
opening and the left set of stitches is
you see them on the needle bed.
Cast on and knit the desired length to the
slash put the left and the center needles
and to hold position.
With the carriage on the right.
Set your machine to hold and
knit across the right needles.
You'll notice that the yarn is in position
to work on the center set of needles.
You'll be binding these stitches
off using the method of your choice.
This bind off creates the
opening for the slash.
Once you're done with the bind off,
push those center needles to out of work
position.
Notice that your yarn is now in position
to work the left set of needles.
But your carriage is on the left, so you
need to make a free pass to get it to the
right hand side.
Push any needles with
stitches into hold position.
With the carriage still on
hold, make your free pass.
Then push the left set of needles into
working position and knit to the left
across these needles.
You'll have completed the first row.
The right set of stitches were knit, the
center set were bound off, and the left
stitches were knit all in one row.
Your row counter should
only advance to one.
The next row we'll fill in the
empty needles to complete the slash.
First hang the cast on rag or the
swatch on the center set of needles.
This will allow you to hang weights
and make the knitting easier.
Manually knit one row of Ravel cord.
In this image, notice the yellow Ravel
cord and the bound off slash behind the
purple cast on rag.
Make sure your carriage
is still set to hold.
Both the center set of needles and the
right needles are in hold knit across the
left needles.
You'll notice now that the yarn is in
position to work the center needles.
Using the method of your choice
cast on those center 20 stitches.
This will finish the opening of the slash.
When you're done casting on.
You'll notice that your yarn is now
in position to knit the right set of
stitches, but the
carriage is on the right.
So put all of the needles in hold for a
free pass and position the carriage on the
left.
Be sure the left and the center needles
are in hold and then knit the right set of
stitches.
Now set your carriage to
knit all the stitches.
Remove the hold setting
and knit across the row.
The slash is complete.
You can continue knitting as desired
When you remove the Ravel cord and the
cast on rag, you'll see your slash.
the pattern she was using called for a
number of random slashes and the edges
just simply rolled
Thank you for watching.
The Knit it Now learning library has
hundreds of techniques on a variety of
subjects at all skill levels.
Please consider a subscription.
And let us help you be a
better machine knitter.